at the production for God of War three
has been some of the most extensive that
we've done for a video game we've got 26
hours of brass sessions that we've done
we've got 12 hours with string ensembles
and we've got 20 hours with a choir
we're recording the strings and brass
here with the AF of M players in the
Santa and San Francisco at Skywalker
Sound we recorded our choir and prog
and we did that remotely over a internet
connection essentially using a digits on
plug-in that allows you to monitor
basically at mp3 quality in real time
and give feedback as though you were
there Skywalker Sound is my favorite
place to record we could actually have a
full 80 piece orchestra playing together
but we could go in and get this
isolation right we could put the brass
in one room we can put the horns in
another we can have you know a 40 p
string section out on the floor we can
have the percussion in another room
right we can have the woodwinds in
another and everybody's all playing
together but behind the scenes we've got
everything isolated so we can go out and
create derivative cues and which which
is which is a lot of what we do so we'll
have maybe two hours of music created
for a game that has 30 hours of gameplay
and we've got to take that two hours and
turn it into maybe four hours of music
to cover that right it's a lot harder to
do if not impossible to do right if
you've only got everybody playing
together all the time the music is first
mocked up by the composer using samples
and synthesizers and when we have those
pieces of music and they sound roughly
like a real Orchestra so that the
director and we can tell where the
composer is going then those in a
multitrack format end up driving the
production all the way through even
though we may record choir on a Tuesday
if we were to record the strings for
that same composition the following
Friday we would still use the synthetic
choir we're using everything from the
mock-up so that everyone's working off
of the same source sound and then in the
end it's all that it all comes together
in the final mix where all the live
elements are brought together even
though samples are getting really really
good these days and it makes it harder
and harder as a musician and a composer
to justify to these guys hey we really
need you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars to record the score even though
the producer may be in love with how it
sounds right now the thing you're still
missing is the emotion that comes out of
out of these and even though it's mostly
angry emotions that are happening god of
war
funny thing about it is forgot it wore
one we were probably a pre-production
about 18 months going through different
styles of music that we thought would
match the game because you could come up
with something really eerie and we spent
maybe like three or four months creating
a score that we thought would be really
good we came up with twenty minutes of
music that was awesome but as soon as we
popped it into the game it got crushed
by the brutality of what was going on in
the game you know so we took another two
or three stabs on it and then we found a
hit on what ultimately became the sound
of god of war
you've got this super super punchy brass
that just kind of punches holes in
you've got this undercurrent of these
really moody strings and then floating
on top of everything you have the choir
just kind of jumping out and ramping it
up and up and uh a lot of the influences
were this heavy kind of like death metal
music like not for the game but once
again what was going on inside of Kronos
his head right so that that had to be
realized with whatever kind of school be
ended up creating